charline migou bonjour
bonjour merci d'avoir accepté notre
invitation ce matin sur rtl france alors
on lisait il ya eu ce dialogue
impossible en guadeloupe et puis
sébastien lecornu en martinique s'est
dit cette fois ouvert à une adaptation
de la loi sur l'obligation vaccinale
alors cette annonce est ce qu'elle peut
calmer une partie de la colère des
entière
oui je pense que oui ça pour rien ce
après cannes et à un calmer les choses
déjà il ya un dialogue qui a été qui a
été fait entre liens entre le ministre
et les partenaires est un fait que les
syndicats donc on attend on attend
impatiemment les résultats de ce
dialogue que ce week-end
à un dialogue qui a eu lieu en
martinique qui n'a pas peut avoir lieu
en guadeloupe comment est ce que vous
vous comprenez cette différence
finalement
alors
je ne sais pas je pense qu'en fait
martinique en lien dans la tente
de tous en fait je pense que les gens
ici ont besoin de retrouver de vie à une
vie normale et je pense qu'ils sont
prêts eux aussi à écouter
et à voir avoir une véritable
envie de faire avancer les choses la
vaccination est ce que c'est pas l'arbre
qui cache la forêt finalement
c'est une des grandes revendications et
évidemment en martinique il y a beaucoup
de problèmes des problèmes qui étaient
déjà là des problèmes à un cave et qui
était déjà remonté en fait il n'y a pas
eu de solution
donc je pense que c'est un tout alors le
préfet la préfecture de martinique à
communiquer sur les prix des produits
pétroliers qui seront appliquées à
partir d'aujourd'hui le prix du gazole
de la bouteille de gaz metz mais le
supercarburant sans plomb lui augmente
de deux centimes alors est ce que il ya
de quoi raviver la colère avec 7,7
hausse du prix du supercarburant
oui effectivement
de pouvoir se voit cela donc c'est ici
sur
[Musique]
allez un petit peu stupéfaits de
l'augmenter de ces carburants et en fait
ça pourrait ça pourrait attiser encore
de la colère au sein des populations
alors il ya eu des tentatives d'incendié
de barrage des nouveaux incidents qui se
sont produits en guadeloupe un juste
après la venue de sébastien lecornu
le refus des représentants syndicaux de
condamner les violences d'un côté
l'envoi des gendarmes supplémentaires
c'est le cas aussi en martinique est ce
qu'il ya un rapport de force qui se met
en place
non je ne vous parle en fait nous ce
qu'on voudrait inscrire souhaite c'est
surtout l'arrêt de ces violences de ces
dégradations qui portent atteinte
à ces populations qui aussi a besoin de
travailler qui a besoin de se soigner
qui a besoin de retrouver une vie
normale donc non il n'ya pas rapport de
forces qu'on souhaite surtout
l'arrêt de tout c'est eux montée de
violences et de dégradations
juste de manger dans l'arctique où on en
est aujourd'hui en martinique de la
situation sécuritaire
donc là on a pu constater d'accalmie de
ces douce et légère accalmie de décéder
de ces dégradations parce qu'il en a
encore eu lieu
[Musique]
avant-hier soir donc
pour l'instant
ça se saurait dire que ça se calme un
peu et est ce que ce malaise que l'on
voit ces derniers temps aux antilles est
ce que finalement ils révèlent un
certain abandon de l'état français ces
dernières et vous en tant que policière
sur le terrain est ce que parfois vous
vous sentez démunis
oui on se sent démuni puisqu'en fait
l'été chez des martinets qui n'a cessé
de solliciter donc notre réagi pour
avoir des effectifs vers nantes pour
avoir du matériel des véhicules dont
royan se sont un petit peu un dealer et
finalement cette réponse d'arc
cet envoi supplémentaire de forces de
l'ordre finalement vous le saluer
aujourd'hui vu le contexte sur place
je suis en discussion cet envoi
supplémentaire de forces de l'ordre de
d'escadron de gendarmerie mobile vous le
saluer vous aujourd'hui ce renfort
ah bah oui ya je pense que sans eux ce
soit était un petit peu compliqué c'est
vrai que le fait d'avoir des renforts ça
permet donc à des effectifs qui sont sur
le territoire de 2 proposait un petit
peu
et je pense qu'elles étaient ces
renforts étaient plus que nécessaires
le ministre d outre mer qui a aussi posé
la question de l'autonomie est ce que ce
sentiment de plus d'autonomie dans les
antilles il est très présent dans la
population alors ses minoritaires
sens inverse si à mon avis je pense que
c'est quelque chose qui a encore un qui
est très minoritaire je ne pense pas en
fait je pense que la population
martiniquaise veut le voir évoluer à
certaines choses avoir des réponses sur
les questions qu'elle pose mais on n'est
pas encore me semblerait arriver à cette
question de tous d'avis qui sont ces
personnes qui ont été interpellés qui
ont érigé ces barrages qui se sont
opposés aux forces de l'ordre
alors pour la plupart ce sont des gens
qui se sont plaintes ils ne font pas des
gens qui réclament quelque chose
je vais poser le mou c'est pour moi
d'aider les grands des gens qui sont là
pour pour casser pour piller faire des
actes de violence pour moi ce ne sont
pas des gens qui font partie de ce
mouvement et qui sont là pour éclairer
quelque chose merci beaucoup charline
migou d'avoir accepté notre invitation
ce matin sur inter france je le rappelle
vous êtes secrétaire administrative
unité sgp police